[Applaudissements]
les chéris regardez il ya un chroniqueur
masqué puisqu'il y avait ma singer ce
week end chroniqueur pas ce qu'est ce
que ça va oui six indices sur la voie
c'est la journée internationale des
célibataires qui est célibataire octobre
à partir de combien de temps on n'est
plus célibataire faut rester comme s est
rencontré lundi soir vous étiez vous
n'êtes jamais rester célibataire n'ont
plus qu'à ce palier en fait puisqu'il
fait fédéraux l'ex commentateur
bousculades et cohues que s'est il passé
que provoquer vous déjà paraissant
public ouais nous nous a rejoints est-ce
que ça m'a français sur dix tu
accepterais que ton conjoint aille voir
ailleurs si vous pouviez le faire aussi
non
sinon je dis non j'ai demandé au
chroniqueur de nous raconter des
anecdotes personnelles sur l'infidélité
céréaliers hamouma partenaires une photo
de moi en train de faire l'amour avec
quelqu'un d'autre c'est moi et moi j'ai
honte non pas ma vie c'est terrible et
tout ce qui s'en veut toujours faire le
malin banon mais j'étais c'est vrai que
j'aime bien photographier
je prends une photo d'un acte sexuel
avec une personne que j'aimais beaucoup
mais qui n'était pas ma partenaire
officiel mais je vends la photo et
abbott qui l'a qui fait aussi m'a dit
[ __ ] si t'arrives la déglingue est-ce
que vous avez déjà envoyé un texto
non c'est la vérité ça va être très très
bref à propos de deux frères jumeaux moi
c'est ma meilleure amie car il n'y a pas
longtemps que son père qui avait un
frère jumeau en fait que son père se
sont donc non toi ma mère elle vient
d'apprendre que mon père et son frère
jumeau
ouais mais je m'en bats les couilles
mais cette fois les lensois ya des gars
comme toi non mais malheureusement il
n'a pas vécu
[Rires]
c'est arrivé ça s'appelle courage et
c'est le nouveau la main au fil de ces
lignes on n'essaie en hommage à toi que
l'effet qu'a répété cet album là avec
toi bon c'est pourquoi un tel succès
puisqu'elle l'a fait je sais mais c'est
son job
[Applaudissements]
qu'il soit là ce soir où l'attend depuis
longtemps asie j'étais avec mozilla
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
si tu veux le voir comme ça c'est bien
jean 690 milles c'est une audio quel
score ne fera jamais tpm des people at
il dit mais moi j'ai tu te sens seul au
milieu de la foule quand que rien osé
toucher ton coeur dis-le moi dis le moi
tu sois trop mal on a tellement déçu que
je tenais d'avoir mal c'est normal
[Musique]
on sait tous plantés
samassa
ça va
ça
[Musique]
non ces techniciens vous avez un défaut
vous parlez souvent de choses que vous
ne connaissez pas rue ce qui n'est
jamais bon
lorsque je parle d' adam
tatum et ses remarques
au départ
[Musique]
juste plus de la journée surtout non ça
c'est mathieu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les caméras
[Musique]
commentez les fours à micro gilles simon
je te vois mieux comme ça ouais bah t'es
encore plus jeunes
[Rires]
ma vie
[Musique]
au jeu
les
[Musique]
est ce que tu me kiffe plus que kim sang
oui
[Applaudissements]
je sais
bon voilà
besoin d'un temps plus longtemps je sais
qu'il est au partage et moussan
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
placez le son que j'écoute le plus
souvent chez aston villa c'est compliqué
on était l'accord final